[موسيقى]
هل صار في محاولات لتحريره من السجن من
القصر يعني قبل بعد اعتقاله كم مره مره
واحده محاولات جديه يعني محاوله جديه يعني
جنود سابقين مثلا او ضباط سابقين ضباط
وقوات خاصه سابقين اعدهم هو يعني الرئيس
الله يرحمه عدهم وكان يشرف عليهم احد
القاده اللي يرافقني احيانا المعتقل يعني
مو قريب من الرئيس ومن الانبار
الرئيس يعني طرحه على الرئيس
هاي الحاله ونقلتها الى ووضع الرئيس خطه
لعمليه الانقضاض عليه الخطه كان محفوفه من
مخاطر يعني انه بعد اطلاق يعني تحريره وين
راح يروح الرئيس
يعني رح يبقى ايضا بطاله
نفدت بالفعل في مره من المرات احدى هذه
العمليات لمحاوله تحريره بعد ما طلب
الرئيس ووضع وضع خطه ركن يعني القوه فوج
لتحرير او قوه اي قوه فوج لتحريره مشغله
المطار مشغلات المنطقه الخضراء القضاء
عليه وخطه كامله متكامله
وتمنقل المعدات الى القريب يعني على
الموقع اللي هو فيه طلب مني ان يعني انقل
هاي الخطه
النائب المرحوم عزت ابراهيم
ليضع يعني لمسات عليها
والقصد حتى يطمئن انه الخطه لانه عده
محاولات جرت لتحرير رئيس ولكن وراها ايران
لانه الايرانيين كانوا متقنين انه
الامريكان ما راح يسمحون باعدامه فحاولوا
عده محاولات
لاختطاف بحجه يعني انهم تابعين لفصائل
المقاومه
[موسيقى]